>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Author, illustrator Kadir Nelson
is a super-talented artist respected
far and wide for his depictions
of all kinds of people.
His illustrations have
appeared in The New Yorker
and Sports Illustrated,
there's like famous magazines.
He's also done album covers
for Michael Jackson and Drake.
His artwork has appeared
on postage stamps.
Kadir Nelson also wrote and
illustrated the award winning books,
"We Are the Ship: The Story of the
Negro League Baseball" and "Heart
and Soul: The Story of
America and African-Americans".
His current book "Blue
Sky White Stars"
with author Sarvinder Naberhaus
is a tribute to the American flag,
exploring those moments when
the flag represents the best
of our country and fellow Americans.
You can have copies of the book
signed between 1:30 and 2:30 p.m.
down at the book-signing area.
So without further ado, let's go
ahead and put our hands together
for author, illustrator
Kadir Nelson.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you very much.
Good afternoon.
Thank you, thank you.
It's a pleasure to be here.
I am a son of Maryland,
I was born in Maryland,
so it's really nice to be home.
So, like I said, it's
a pleasure to be here.
I am thrilled to talk to you about
my new book "Blue Sky White Stars".
It's written by Sarvinder
Naberhaus and it is a celebration
of the American flag,
of the symbolism
of the flag and the people.
Now, if you not familiar
with my work,
I've been illustrating
books for quite some time.
I've illustrated probably
about 30 books.
I've been drawing since I was
very little, about 3 years old.
Do we have any 3 year olds here?
Any 3 year olds?
Does anybody have a 3 year
old brother or sister?
Is anybody ever been 3 years
old before, at least once?
Yep, I've been drawing that
long, since I was that little
and I've been practicing every day.
And if you want to get good
at something, what do you do?
You practice right?
That's the only way
to get better at it.
So I've been practicing
for a very, very long time.
And recently I was asked
to illustrate this book
"Blue Sky White Stars" and I
thought it was a really great way
to celebrate where I'm from.
I'm from America and I wanted
to celebrate the American flag.
Its people, the diversity of its
people, the diversity of the land
and this was a great opportunity
to celebrate all those things.
So I'm going to take you, has
anybody seen the book yet?
No, well if you haven't you're
going to get to see it now.
So here are a few images from
the book "Blue Sky White Stars".
So basically what the author
did, the text is very sparing
but it's very powerful and
poignant and it makes a parallel
between the colors of the flag, the
symbolism of the flag, and the land,
the people, and its history.
So the book starts off
with very simple text,
it says "Blue sky white stars" and
of course, in the American flag,
you'll see the blue
behind the white stars.
And each of the flags,
they correlate to the time
in history that's being shown in
the image on the opposite page.
So here you'll see a picture
of the Statue of Liberty,
blue sky white stars [inaudible]
opposite page you'll see the flag
so you can make a connection
between both images.
The next page, it says "Red rows"
so you'll see a red row of what?
Of trees. And then on the opposite
side you see red rows of the flag.
The next page says "White
rows" so you'll see white rows
on the right hand side
on the American flag
and on the opposite side
you'll see images of,
anybody know what that is?
What is it?
A carriage.
It's from the Oregon Trail,
see all the covered wagons.
And you'll see white lines
of the covered wagons.
And then it says "Red,
white, and blue" so you get
to see the colors of
the flag in nature.
So you see a red barn and red
white and blue sky and snow.
Old Glory, so you'll
see a contrast of nature
and then a man-made demonstration
of Old Glory, which are fireworks
over the Brooklyn Bridge.
Sea waves and then see waves.
Sew together won nation.
Now you see it's a play on
words, you see how she's written
"Sew together" s-e-w
"won nation" w-o-n nation
and then "So together one
nation" which is, again,
my focus on this book was to
celebrate America as I know it.
America is a very diverse land, full
of diverse people, and it was made,
built by a very diverse people.
Well-worn, look you
see Abraham Lincoln,
his face after having been President
for several years and faced a lot
of adversity, so his face
became very well-worn just
like the American flag.
Woven together, so you see marchers
on the mall during the civil rights
movement on the March on Washington
and everyone is there together
marching for jobs and freedom.
And here's another
image, it's all American.
So you'll see on the left-hand side,
you'll see a baseball game played
at Wrigley Field and then you'll
see a grandfather and his son
or great=grandfather and his
son, a great grandson listening
to the game on the radio.
Now this one was interesting
because I wanted to,
whenever I'm illustrating
a book I think of images
that make me feel good and one of
my precious memories was sitting
on the porch with my
grandmother eating Crackerjacks
when I was a little
kid in Atlantic City.
I figured I'd tie those two
images, those memories together.
And also, quite interestingly
enough, I painted this in;
it was well before, I think it
was in April or May of last year.
And then the following
fall, the Cubs ended
up winning the World Series,
so that was my prediction
of the World Series.
Stand proud, so here we have
an image of many of the people
who participated or experienced
the American Civil War
of all races and genders.
There's actually a woman who's
standing second from the right,
well there's Harriet
Tubman on the right,
and then there's a woman
who's posed as a male soldier.
Apparently there are a
number of women who fought,
who saw battle during the Civil War
who had donned Civil War
uniforms posing as men
so that they could
participate in the battle.
And also there's Native Americans,
there's a Japanese soldier,
a Spanish soldier all the way
on the left and a white soldier
on the second from the right,
so it was a combined effort,
so I wanted to emphasize that
part of American history.
And on the right, you have the
graduate, who's a female graduate,
who's a doctoral candidate who's
graduating, receiving an honor.
My girlfriend, very
graciously, posed for this one,
so that was very nice of her.
Here's one of [inaudible] rising
up, so you have a parallel
between an Army vet, military
veteran flying a flag as well as,
on the right-hand side, you'll see
the, I think it's the Apollo 11,
the first spacecraft
that landed on the moon,
not the rocket, but what was inside.
And initially, actually
when I was doing this image,
I made a mistake of, I had
like the Challenger shuttle,
one of the shuttles, the
space shuttles that was,
it was not launched until years and
years later, so I had to go back
and change that to make sure
that it was historically accurate
because I'm sure, I know there
are a lot of people out there
who really love history and they
love to tell you what you did wrong.
So I didn't want that to happen,
so I went back and changed it.
And there's the same rocket flying
past the American bald eagle.
So I thought the author did a really
great job of making a parallel
between the symbolism of the
flag and the actual history,
actual people, landscape
and so forth.
So here, they've landed on the moon
and is planting the flag there,
so you'll see reflection
in the flag.
But I did make one
mistake on this image
but I'm not going to
share that with you.
I'll let you find that,
it's not that hard to find.
Red, white, and blue
sky, white stars forever,
so you'll see the flag
has been planted
and the astronauts are
heading back to the,
I forget what that thing is called,
whatever the spacecraft is that land
on the moon to go back home.
And you see the Earth, the
lander, what did you call it?
Lander, that makes perfect sense.
Okay, hold your question;
I'm almost done, almost done.
That is awesome.
So on the back cover, you'll
see an image, it's a reverse
of what you see on the cover except
now you can see what they're looking
at, all the people are looking up
at something and you see the stars
in their eyes and you
can see the fireworks.
And I don't know if you can see it
very well but my favorite detail
of this image is the light coming
through the little boy's ears,
I don't know if you can see that.
So this book, I think I worked
on it for about maybe four
or five months creating the
art work, usually it takes
about that long, between three
and five months to create images
for a thirty-two or
so page picture book.
Most of the paintings are
about the same size as you see,
actually that's not right, the
paintings are about twice as large
as what you see in the book or more.
Some of them are even much larger,
the image of the fireworks
is probably the largest image
in the book, largest
painting in the book.
People often have questions
about my technique or the way
that I create the paintings
and it's very interesting.
I have a video and it shows exactly
how fast I can create a painting,
I'm really fast.
Okay, you've got to pay attention.
Here we go.
I'm working on the
all-American painting here,
the great-grandfather,
great-grandson.
Fast. So I work subtractively,
so I put paint on the canvas
and then I wipe the paint
away to create values.
That's just the first step.
And then after that, I'll paint
over that and then I'll paint
over that again, it
usually takes about three
or four days per painting.
So we have a little bit less
than ten minutes to go and I want
to give you an opportunity to
ask questions if you have them.
Who had a question?
Someone over here had a question.
What's your question?
Oh yeah, you can go up to the
microphone to ask your question.
He forgot?
Oh, that happens.
Okay, we have another.
If you have a question, just walk up
to the microphone and stand in line
so we can get through it.
No, not this microphone,
that microphone.
He said "microphone".
>> How'd you draw the
picture so fast?
>> Oh, well that was a joke.
That was, I think it's called
time lapse on your phone.
It records you in real time and
then it speeds it up real fast.
>> When did you, like when would
you normally finish any book?
>> When do I normally
finish any book?
>> Yeah.
>> I work on probably one
or two books per year.
>> Whoa.
>> Why [inaudible] so fast?
>> Say that again.
>> Why do you finish books so fast?
>> I don't really work that fast,
that was just kind
of a camera trick.
It takes a lot longer to do that.
>> How do you, like how do
you draw the pictures so well?
>> Oh, because I have been
doing this for a long time
and the more you do something
the better you get at it.
So when you practice and practice,
you get better, that's the key
to getting better,
repetition, doing it over
and over again til you master it.
>> Thank you.
>> You're welcome.
>> How good are you?
>> Okay, well I think
you answer that question.
[inaudible]
>> I can draw so fast and
I can draw a building.
>> Nice. I don't like drawing
buildings; I don't like it at all.
That makes sense.
>> What's your favorite book--
>> My favorite-
>> that you like to draw?
>> That I like to draw?
I always say my favorite book is
the next one that I'm working on,
so the next book that I'm
working on, there's two books,
one book is called "This is for us".
It's written by Kwame Alexander.
And then the next book after
that is a book that I've written
and will illustrate called
"Basketball" it'll be
about the history of basketball.
I'm really excited about that.
>> I know the question you
answered in the middle of the story,
"No Shadows on the Moon".
>> No shadows on the booth?
Oh, on the moon.
Oh, there are no shadows
on the moon?
Oh, I didn't know that.
[inaudible] go back and fix it.
>> Do you talk to the author before
you write like draw the pictures,
like talk to the author about what
you want to paint [inaudible]?
>> Do I talk to the author?
Usually, I don't.
Usually I like to have
my own creative space
to create the artwork.
Sometimes the author likes to tell
me what to do but that doesn't work
out because I don't get to
tell the author what to do,
so they don't get to do the same.
>> How did you come up
with the title of the book?
>> Well, I didn't come up with the
title for "Blue Sky" the author came
up with the title for that one.
But usually if I'm working on
a book, if I've written it,
and I'm thinking about a title,
I try to think of something
that will encompass the whole
book, that'll make sense,
that'll put it all in a
nutshell and make people think
about what the book might be about,
something that will
grab their attention.
>> Did you mix colors?
>> Do I mix colors?
All the time, half of
the painting is done
on a palette, is mixing colors.
That's half of the painting.
>> What is your favorite book--
>> What's my favorite
book that I've written
or my favorite book of all time?
>> When you were a kid.
>> Oh, I really liked
"Where the Wild Things Are".
That was my favorite.
>> Where do you get
your inspiration from?
>> I get my inspiration from
all over, something that I read,
something that I might see,
from music, from an experience
that I've had, everything finds
its way into the work that I do.
>> Do you paint from
photos or real life?
>> I do both.
Sometimes I'll take photos of myself
posing as my subject or friends
or family or I'll find
photographs in books in the library
or on the Internet and film,
wherever I can find it.
>> When did you start drawing?
>> When did I what?
>> start drawing.
>> When did I start drawing?
I started drawing when I
was about three years old.
>> What was your first illustration?
>> My first illustration, well
the first drawing I ever did was a
self-portrait when I
was probably about three
but it didn't really look
like me, it was pretty bad.
I was new you know.
>> What's your favorite colors?
>> I don't have a favorite
color, I like all the colors.
>> What year [inaudible]
you start drawing?
>> I started drawing in 1977.
He's like "that means
nothing to me."
>> Who's your favorite artists?
>> Oh, I have a lot of
artists that I really like.
It's a very long list.
You ever heard of John
Singer Sargent?
Really like him.
M.C. Wyatt.
It's a very long list.
Those are some of my favorites.
Michelangelo, I like him too.
Everybody likes him.
>> How do you get your
ideas for your books?
>> I think of my past experiences.
When I read the words, I
see pictures, when you read,
you see pictures in your head right?
You can imagine what's going on?
So whatever I think about when I
read the words then I'll make a
sketch of that.
And if it works, great,
if it doesn't,
then I have to keep working on it.
>> How long does it
take you to decide what
to incorporate into [inaudible]?
>> How long does it
take, say it again.
take you to decide what
to incorporate into [inaudible]?
>> How long does it take what
to incorporate in the drawings?
I'm actually pretty quick.
I can read a manuscript and have
all the sketches done in a few days.
You know I just read it over
and over and over again.
>> [inaudible]
>> Okay, I think we're about,
I think we've almost ran,
we've run out of time but
thank you all so much.
Thank you for all your
questions and getting in line,
thank you, I appreciate it.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.